i want to begin by thanking all of the
incredible
medical professionals the doctors the
nurses everybody
at walter reed medical center i think
it's the finest in the world
for the incredible job they've been
doing i came here wasn't feeling so well
i feel much better now we're working
hard to get me all the way back i have
to be back
because we still have to make america
great again we've done an awfully good
job of that
but we still have steps to go and we
have to finish that job
and i'll be back i think i'll be back
soon
and i look forward to finishing up the
campaign the way it was started and the
way we've been doing and
the kind of numbers that we've been
doing we've been so proud of it
but this was something that happened and
it's happened to millions of people all
over the world and i'm fighting for them
not just in the u.s i'm fighting for
them all over the world
we're going to beat this coronavirus or
whatever you want to call it
and we're going to beat it soundly so
many things have happened
if you look at the therapeutics which
i'm taking right now
some of them and others are coming out
soon that are looking like
uh frankly they're miracles if you want
to know the truth they're miracles
people criticize me when i say that
but we have things happening that look
like they're miracles coming down from
god
so i just want to tell you that i'm
starting to feel good
uh you don't know over the next period
of a few days i guess that's the real
test so we'll
be seeing what happens over those next
next couple of days
i just want to be so thankful for all of
the support i've seen
whether it's on television or reading
about it
i most of all appreciate what's been
said
by the american people by almost a
bipartisan consensus of american people
it's a beautiful thing to see
and i very much appreciate it and i
won't forget it i promise you that
i also want to thank the leaders of the
world for
their condolences and their they know
what we're going through they know what
as your leader what i have to go through
but i had no choice
because i just didn't want to stay in
the white house i was given that
alternative
stay in the white house lock yourself in
don't ever leave
don't even go to the oval office just
stay upstairs and enjoy it
don't see people don't talk to people
and just be done with it and
i can't do that i had to be out front
and
this is america this is the united
states this is the greatest country in
the world this is the most powerful
country in the world i can't be locked
up in a room upstairs and
totally safe and just say hey
whatever happens happens i can't do that
we have to confront problems as a leader
you have to confront problems there's
never been a great leader that
would have done that so that's where it
is
i'm doing well i want to thank everybody
our first lady is doing very well
melania
asked me to say something as to
the respect that she has for our country
the love that she has for our country
and we're both doing well melania is
really handling it very nicely
as you've probably read she's slightly
younger than me just a little tiny bit
and therefore just we know the disease
we know the
situation with age versus
younger people and melania is handling
it
statistically like it's supposed to be
handled
and that makes me very happy and it
makes the country very happy
but i'm also doing well and i think
we're going to have a very good result
again over the next few days we're going
to probably know for sure
so i just want to thank everybody out
there everybody all over the world
specifically the united states the
outpouring of love has been
incredible i will never forget thank you
very much